good evening dr. Martin Luther King the
apostle of non-violence in the civil
rights movement has been shot to death
in Memphis Tennessee faith have issued
an all-points in January of 1968
Vietcong and North Vietnamese forces
launched the Tet Offensive against South
Vietnamese troops and their allies from
the United States in April James Earl
Ray shot and killed dr. Martin Luther
King on a balcony in Memphis Tennessee
and in June robert francis kennedy was
pronounced dead on the presidential
campaign trail after a 22 caliber
revolver inflicted gunshot wounds in a
crowded ballroom for America this was a
tumultuous year but it's the year hangar
13 is hoping to portray with mafia 3 and
its lead character Lincoln clay
[Music]
the things that we talked about you know
with the writing team in particular it's
like look tell an authentic story tell
something that feels true to life you
know we steal that quote from Stephen
King like one of the best books on
writing is Stephen King's on writing and
he just hammers at home again and again
and again is you know at the end of the
day the worst thing you can do is not be
honest you know so you got to tell the
truth and in terms of 1968 selecting
that year I think this was largely
driven by the fact that when people
think of the 60s there's these huge kind
of touchstone moments and one of the
things we really work to do in terms of
creating that specific time and place
that we think is very important to the
franchise is interweaving those
real-world elements with our narrative
you couldn't exist in the world with
without having an opinion on one of
those things so it really caused people
to to kind of land barely very solidly
on one side of issues or another and so
I think that just that was the catalyst
to kind of start bringing out more
conflict in there
[Applause]
as you described it was very tall Trish
year and I think it kind of crystallizes
a lot of the shifting social dynamics
that are going on the country around
that time the shifting dynamics the
growing that were going on in the Mafia
itself the mythology of the fraternity
of the Mafia was kind of losing a little
bit of its bloom around that period of
time you know they were fracturing they
were losing a little bit a little bit of
their foothold around the country
whereas sort of subordinate criminal
groups run by minorities we're a little
bit more on the rise you start seeing
dudes like Nicky Barnes rising up in New
York and getting their autonomy in the
60s in the 70s and I think 1968 was a
great jumping-off point for that and as
painful as it is we hope that this time
things are gonna be different and that
when it's time to rebuild we won't just
repeat what we've done in the past
and that may be justice and peace will
finally prevail we're able to use real
history in our fictional history by
essentially allowing it to serve as a
backdrop the framing device for our game
is documentary footage that it takes
place throughout the course of the story
you know seated throughout a lot of that
are the the real-life events you know
assassinations of Ramat political
figures a lot of the civil rights unrest
and rioting in protests going on around
the assassination of MLK and using those
things and having actual characters in
the world comment on these moments it
gives us a sense of reality it also
grounds us it gives us a sense of time
in place 1968 was was about the time
that we people started to question what
we were doing in Vietnam and how long is
it gonna actually be going on you know
the politics of 1968 I think we start to
full-bore go into that that kind of era
of cynicism that then pervades to me you
know dissatisfaction with the government
distrust of the government you know it
starts getting worse and worse the 70s
for getting all that kind of stuff
and that is reflected in our story it's
also reflected in kind of our story
about the Mafia itself you know these
institutions that were once trusted
these institutions that were once kind
of considered venerable the the cuddley
Godfather version of the Mafia which is
all about this fraternity this
Brotherhood that protects their then a
ruined
we're dismantling that a little bit
we're seeing Lincoln confronting and I'm
not here to steal your heroin with you
I'm here to make you pay for what you
did to Sammy Nellis Robinson I watched
you stab Ellis in the gut
[Music]
and then in terms of Lincoln as a
character you know we spent a lot of
time basically crafting the character
that we think the player will empathize
with so it's things like you know he's
an orphan the offering his shuts down
he's put out on the street he falls in
with Sammy Robinson who heads up the
black mob as a biological son named
Ellis and they kind of basically adopt
Lincoln and their family but he's kind
of always had this hole inside of him
you know he's always searching for
something and he thinks he can find it
in the army so he joins the army and the
game actually starts after he served he
was four years in the military and he's
still searching for that and I think
that's a universal theme for a lot of
people because you know you get out of
high school you get out of college or
even you know you know midlife crisis
people always have Pete I think most
people have this moment in their life
let's say what am i doing let's work my
place where do I belong writing Lincoln
players and minority characters the same
as writing an inner character
we're just true to him as a gifted
antihero
existing in this space his experience is
going to be informed by his blackness
and I think that's very very important
to the story but that's that's all in
the research and that's all in kind of
our own lived experience and talking
about how he's going to react to this
world a way that might be different from
the way I say if he don't would have
reacted similar circumstances in mafia
to you know Vito had a lot more
opportunities and social navigation that
the Lincoln might not have in Mafia 3
and it's it's kind of interesting being
able to articulate that to the player to
be able to show hey some of these spaces
are restricted to you some opportunities
of being able to advance in this world
are restricted to you well you know at
the same time that's giving them sort of
a stark polemic about you know this is
what racism is like
like snow that's certainly something to
set up we attempted to to make different
parts of the city feel dynamic based on
where you know where Lincoln is going
the police are going to react to him a
lot quicker than some of the more
affluent neighborhoods and they're gonna
be a little bit slower in the poor
neighborhoods they're gonna be a lot
more aggressive when they show up at
certain neighborhoods we really just
tried to make it feel like this world is
reactive to Lincoln as a black man in
1968 well at the same time kind of
striking this fine balance between not
making you feel like you're constantly
under siege because I don't I don't know
if that necessarily would be oh crap
right fun
I think there's a real tendency to take
a character like Lincoln and put them up
on a pedestal because we're like well
you know we'll be seen as insensitive if
we if we you know don't show them any
other way as other than perfect and
that's that to me is is even more
insensitive man is more you know kind of
is worse than then showing him as a real
person right so he has flaws you know we
all have flaws and I think that's a more
honest portrayal than you know against
something where it's like well we're
just gonna make him this ideal this
idealized version of you know mixed race
protagonists writing this like he's not
he's you know he's loyal but to a fault
you know he's greedy on some level he is
an aggressive character on some level
because he's a criminal and he's got to
go out there and he's got to make
changes in the world the only way he
knows how
which is you know again some ways at the
end of the gun we look at the social
issues of 1968 and and quickly those
related to race from those related to
the war not as set-dressing but and this
may sound like it's being a fine point
but his backdrop for all of this they're
all informing the decisions that MIT
Lincoln makes as a character and the way
that the world interacts with Lincoln
because racism is so so much more effort
during that period we're able to reflect
that in the way the police interact to
Lincoln in the way that some people on
the street will react to Lincoln in ways
that other games might not necessarily
be able to Lincoln's own experience as a
soldier in Vietnam we're able to kind of
get a little bits and pieces of that
through his interactions with with
Donovan and father James who himself is
a you know survivor of a previous war
who I reflect that in the moment
tomorrow at the moment storytelling
rather than just having people kind of
divulge oh hey Lincoln you're suffering
from PTSD what does that mean for you
versus having Lincoln be an angry
dangerous character in this space
informed by his experience in the war
but really I think the thing that
Lincoln brings back with him from
Vietnam is almost in a weird way some
confidence
personally I don't think he's the hero
and the normal sense of you know of
going out and you know saving kittens
but we say he's gifted because he is
gifted and in a very specific way in
that and part of his be comes from his
background Vietnam where when he was in
the Special Forces he was actually part
of this thing which were going to become
called the Phoenix program and basically
they would recruit indigenous people to
fight the NVA in the VC so it's a gift
he has of bringing in kind of disparate
groups and kind of aligning them and
pointing them in a direction that not
only benefits them but also benefits him
and that's exactly what he does when
some Arkana betrays him and you know
wipes out his family and now in our
current story after all the stuff that
goes down and needs to form all these
new alliances those are almost kind of
like a family of necessity but as the
game progresses it's very important for
Lincoln that he start establishing
relationships with these people
he starts finding kind of common ground
with these people who have suffered in
similar ways to them who have needs who
are humans like he's a human but who
also deeply deeply flawed and you know
damaged and dangerous these are all
things that I don't think you know we
could go out and find any one person
that live Lincoln's experience but it
allows you to walk in in the shoes of
somebody that you can't now today right
there's no way for I can't be all those
things right and hopefully the game
allows me an opportunity to do that and
explore some of those things a little
bit I mean again at the end of the day
we did want to create a compelling story
we wanted to come create you know really
fun gameplay if the game's not fun and
everything else kind of doesn't matter
right because it's a game and that's
first and foremost our goal but again if
you can walk away from it again and
think a little bit and go like you know
why was Lincoln treated this way in this
area of town versus this way you know in
this other area town you're like oh it's
because you know everybody sees him as
black in 1968 that makes sense and it
makes you think about that and it makes
you think about the world today in kind
of a new way and then
think you know we've done something
hopefully there is a little bit special
hangar 13 could have played it safe with
mafia 3 the studio could have stuck to
the franchise's roots portraying the
inner workings of the Italian mob and
the downfall of powerful gangsters but
Blackman and his team see more potential
in their first release they see more
potential in the power of stories they
see more potential in video games
inherent ability to let us empathize I
think the real power of games is that it
allows to allow you to be somebody or
not so in this case you know everyone
who plays the game they get a play as
link and clay and they get experience
1968 you know new Bordeaux and I think
that really speaks to the power of games
and the fact that we can transport the
player to the specific time and place
and let them see not only see the world
through the eyes of Lincoln clay but
also see how the world views Lincoln
clay as a man I think is really powerful
in the interesting
but at the end of the day you have to
have your vision and if you stop all the
time to kind of pivot then you're never
gonna make forward progress you're never
gonna get anywhere because there's
always a game that comes out you know
every month a new game comes out that
has something cool in it that we could
have chased honestly once inside of our
hands it becomes part of the culture it
becomes part of something that people
have comment on and I think one of the
exciting things about Lincoln Clay as a
character is that you know he's someone
that many people are to have very very
different reactions to and he's gonna
live on as he's going to take on a life
example that we can't even be Rhea that
we can't anticipate
you know when your release it's a you
know a little bit of a yourself going
out into the world and so we're you know
kind of holding our breath just to see
what the reaction is
we are cruel and wicked people
[Music]